[Music]
the climate crisis
is a defining challenge of this century
the united states steps back up to the
podium it left empty for the last four
years
we have to mobilize in unprecedented
ways to meet a challenge that is fast
accelerating
robert downey jr finds a new role as a
green activist
this really for me is the role of a
lifetime being a
semi-retired uh superhero this is real
deal stuff pipeline problems force a
small community in alberta
to go soul searching it's empty there's
absolutely no one here
and the attendees of the first digital
davos aim to ensure
nobody is left behind if we are really
going to be moving to a net zero carbon
environment
it all of society has to move this is
also about driving growth and driving
jobs forward in new york city i'm kaylee
lynes and this
is bloomberg green
iron man is going green the footprint
coalition which is founded by actor
robert downey jr in 2019
is part vc part non-profit part
production house
and all centered around climate change
and it's more than just a win
it's now his full-time job this week the
footprint coalition announced it would
inject funds into
insect what's that well it's among the
world's biggest insect farms
and now one of the best funded with more
than 372 million dollars in series c
bugs are emerging as a high-protein
low-carbon alternative for among other
things
animal feed bloomberg's anne marie
hordone spoke to robert downey jr about
this new job
as a climate investor and philanthropist
and what he calls
the role of a lifetime robert what
solutions have you seen that
you've been most excited about in the
climate world
i think it's so funny that the the cloud
paper the bamboo toilet paper
uh solution i i don't know why but this
was a year of toilet paper so much
discussion about it so i think when
things are
topical there's always an interest uh
there but to speak about
insect sometimes what gets me thinking
about how could i be additive
is i know that if i go on uh you know
stephen colbert and i hold up a bag of
this mealworm flower
it's just there's an artifact to show
we're not talking about something
because we want to talk about how dudley
do right we are
this is something that's happening and
it can happen at scale
next step is i come talk to you in six
months and we have a
a mealworm uh protein bar together
and and we have a little taste test
comparison and all of a sudden it's like
we're
normalizing these things you've said
once
i'm a one-man carbon footprint nightmare
colossus
has your work over the past year and a
half
really with footprint coalition has this
impacted
the decisions you make in terms of your
lifestyle at all
i am in a shed between
a shipping container and a chicken coop
and um and that's something i'd love to
talk about later just how we
are are trying to kind of demonstrate
things you can do in the last year i
said how come all these
fat cats have made billions of dollars
while we've been struggling there's this
pandemic and there's this
tsunami of you know the the
environmental crisis coming down then i
stopped and said wait a minute
when did i have my windfall right after
the last economic downturn from 2008
till 2019
so it is that thing of you're pointing
one finger and this three pointing back
at you
i think the realization of the future
even of
entertainment is a whole uh
sector to become involved with i mean we
burn
a lot a lot a lot a lot of you know gas
and other fuels and all that just so we
can
make entertainment so well is there a
way hollywood movies could be made
more green like could we have a greener
version of iron man
there certainly is and i think a lot of
it too is you just have to
look at the infrastructure that's been
there since the 30s 40s 50s
and then some innovation after
mid-century to now but
it is something it's not a dirty little
secret and every major studio and
streamer
wants to be net zero but again i think
the the coalition
part of our job and our skill set
enables us to literally say not only
do we want to not just point a a wag a
finger at you
we're going to come to you with five
solutions that you could implement
yeah robert you have over 48 million
instagram followers you coming out and
talking about climate
could really push people even just
them wanting to be more educated about
it do you hope
other actors or other influencers will
join you in this
anyone who's arriving now is is late to
the party we know what this next
four-year horizon is going to be we know
that it is is
is the thing but you know i want to go
back to something that you you'd ask
before
because we all come up against
bureaucratic inefficiencies and really
part of what sparked this was
in some of my talks with the people who
really could uh
affect a fairly instantaneous change
they were zip tied
to dealing with the siloed mission
statement
of their mega corporation and so that to
me is something else that the coalition
wants to address is that's all good and
fine
we get it but that is not the kind of
conglomerate we need to bring to bear
for really going to deal with this
it has to be more principally based on
just like how can we break down
all these turf wars that are going on at
least
where we can if you were to join me
again in five years time
what would be something you'd hope you'd
be able to accomplish
i would say there'd been uh some policy
that the fund
had had grown and and was at uh
numbers that would be commensurate with
what success would look like
that we had a consumer facing products
that these things had been done to scale
a nice percentage of them and also that
that thing you can't
know like i love that part of i don't
know what it's going to be
but i know that we're going to do
whatever it takes to get there i think
if i can look back
and feel i've been so activated i mean
this really for me is
the role of a lifetime being a
semi-retired uh
superhero this is real deal stuff
and it just lights up a different
constellation in my psyche
and uh mr shohoff and uh cropa and i we
we're just we're really it's a really
fun ride because the stakes are so high
you can't deny it coming up the defining
challenge
of the century why the climate crisis
will make or break
the future of the global economy we
speak with the imf's managing director
christolina jorgeva this is bloomberg
it's a whole government approach put
climate change at the center of our
domestic
national security and foreign policy
it's advancing conservation revitalizing
communities in cities and in the fall on
the farmlands
and securing environmental justice our
plans are ambitious
but we are america
[Music]
we will see an ambition to
invest in low carbon climate resilient
economy given the signs that climate
change
requires immediate action this is the
decade and so we wanted to start by
saying
let's make some good commitments all the
companies that i interact with in the us
are very committed they believe climate
change is a real issue climate change
is not going to be fixed by a central
bank we want to invest
in clean technology we do need uh real
breakthroughs
that was the conversation on the davos
mountaintops in january of 2020
climate change was beginning to steal
the spotlight and increasingly becoming
a priority in the world of business and
policy
but then kovit intervened dominating
every part of human life
as society adjusts to a new normal the
urgency of climate change is going to
the front burner
i see a tremendous effort in terms
of rallying now behind net zero
not only governments but business this
is about
putting uh public money uh but then also
leveraging in
uh many multiples in terms of private
funding to get our economies going we've
shown in the uk that green growth is
possible climate is our biggest
threat um you know we'll get over
this pandemic we will resolve it climate
is something where we will need to put
the same efforts
we used to fight the pandemic
if we are really going to be moving to a
net zero carbon environment
it all of society has to move
governments worldwide are going to need
to invest
in the r d of how to prepare for
climate change climate change if we do
not tackle visit could be the next big
let's say virus who is much more
damaging
and long-term consequences
from bloomberg's headquarters in new
york i'm kaylee lynes
well at this year's digital davos
climate change was once again
the primary concern but how much will it
cost if the world
doesn't act soon this week's imf world
economic outlook projects growth to
rebound
in 2021. advanced economies though will
continue to feel the pain of the
coronavirus crisis
while emerging economies will recover
more quickly
but the organization insists that the
long-term health of the global economy
is dependent upon how green the
coronavirus recovery is
we dig into the details with the
managing director crystallina
the climate crisis is a defining
challenge of this century unmitigated it
would cost us
somewhere between a couple of percentage
points to a quarter of
a global gdp disappearing if we don't
act and that makes it immediately a
primary focus of the work of the imf
there are three key priorities one
to help our members integrate climate
resilience
and low carbon growth in their economic
policies
second we are very concerned about
risks to financial stability we want to
help
with standards to integrate climate
related
risks and to move towards stress testing
for these risks last but not least we
want
to generate better data for decision
makers
a new dashboard that integrates climate
indicators
into macroeconomic indicators
how do you convince economies that are
just desperate to get back on track when
it comes to growth
to take on that short-term pain as they
transform their economies to become
greener
the immediate objective for countries
is to direct those of them that have
fiscal space
some of it towards green investments
to revitalize growth and revitalize
job creation when we did our research we
concluded that
a green infrastructure investment push
can add 0.7 percentage points
to growth over the next 15 years the job
benefits of moving towards public
investment and creating
incentives for private investments for
climate resilience low carbon
is incredibly positive do you see any
economic
response that you think is sufficient
right now well what we have seen in the
beginning of the crisis and rightly so
is concentration on measures to just
protect the economy from collapse
in october we took stock how much of the
fiscal injection went green and
only a tiny fraction about two percent
since then though
what we see is a number of countries
fault
advanced economies and some emerging
markets like china
emphasizing stimulus in transformational
terms
where we are worried is countries that
have very limited fiscal space
especially countries with high burden of
debt and there
it is so very important that we generate
grants and concessional financing so
they
also have fiscal space to do
what is right some economists say you
could have a win-win with these
countries if you start financing the
debt
and you link it to climate goals do you
think that's the right
response for some countries that are
in very deep that distress
the right approach is that restructuring
possibly that relief for many countries
with significant debt levels where that
is sustainable
that for climate arrangements can be
very
beneficial for everybody first we can
substitute expensive debt with cheap
green debts creating an instrument that
allows these countries
to access the enormity of liquidity that
exists today second there can be
programs in which countries commit to
transform
their economies using a debt
operation that converts their debt to
domestic
climate action commitment every single
instrument at our disposal must be put
to work do you expect the united states
to now lead the charge with this a new
administration that has climate change
as a top priority
it is very welcoming that u.s has
rejoined the
paris agreement not for the
signature but for the action
it would generate it is also a chance
for the big committees to come together
should they
agree on a carbon price floor that would
give predictability to the world economy
and it would serve as a big accelerator
of the transformation
we have to undertake if we all act
in a determined manner this transition
is not only possible but it is
good for our societies good for jobs and
having the u.s
stepping up gives a much better chance
for 21 to be
a truly consequential year in this
transformation
what do you hope is the one thing these
global economies
could achieve in 2021 the most important
thing we can do today is to link
the recovery from the pandemic to the
transition
to the new climate economy it is
once in a century crisis but that makes
it also
once in a century opportunity utilizing
this opportunity
is going to be the task that we at the
imf
will embrace and promote in our policy
dialogue with our membership coming up
the pipeline predicament just hours
after assuming office
president biden canceled the
construction of the keystone pipeline in
alberta
but where does that leave the community
this
is bloomberg green
[Music]
in new york i'm kaylee lynes and this is
bloomberg green
now let's get your green brief here's
jennifer zabazadja
here's the climate news you need to know
this week
failure is not an option at the cop 26
summit
later this year that's the stark message
of u.s climate envoy john kerry who says
it's the world's
last chance to step up action on cutting
carbon emissions
he's vowing the us will make good on its
promises and become a leader in the
fight against global warming
could president biden declare a climate
emergency
that's what the senate's top democrat
chuck schumer is calling for
it's a controversial move allowing the
president to bypass
congress on certain issues and funnel
money to clean energy projects
everyone is fixated on the price of
bitcoin but one thing they often don't
think about
is its impact on the environment
according to digi economists the kryptos
carbon footprint is about 37
million tons that's about the same as
new zealand a country of five
million people and elon musk is offering
a 100
million dollar prize for the best carbon
capture technology
the world's richest man wants to find
ways to lower the cost
and use the emissions to make rocket
fuel carbon capture can be used to trap
greenhouse gases from
plants and factories or even directly
from the air
i'm jennifer zabasaja in new york kaylee
after eight years of back and forth
president biden canceled the keystone xl
oil pipeline project
within hours of assuming office the only
problem
construction on the pipeline was already
underway
now the citizens of oye and alberta have
to make new plans for the community
bloomberg's robert tuttle visited the
small town to investigate
it's empty there's absolutely no one
here the
keystone xl pipeline is empty pipe just
lying around here
[Music]
i'm visiting you from oyen alberta
and until a few days ago this was kind
of ground zero for construction of the
keystone xl pipeline that all pretty
much came to a halt a few days ago when
joe biden
on his first day in office as u.s
president signed an executive order that
rescinded a
permit that was given by the previous
administration to build the pipeline
fairly recently as many as a thousand
people
just staying here working on this oil
pipeline
i did not expect to see that in the
first hundred days
i had a guy born with me and he comes in
at 10 o'clock
and he says hey i'm done he left i think
there's still 300
guys left you know they didn't all just
exit town just like that
you know they can't leave the pipe
exposed so they're going to close that
up they'll be done here in a month
people are still holding on to the hope
that the project isn't dead
you're still kind of hopeful that maybe
this project can be revived do you think
uh yeah we're we're waiting for news
from transcanada and we're just
we'll just go forward until we not hear
those news but it's clear
that many of the workforce here are
getting ready to leave or have left
keystone xl was a very controversial
pipeline it was going to be built to
carry
as much as 800 000 barrels a day of oil
sands crewed from alberta
down into the united states its critics
claimed that it would contribute to
global warming by fostering development
of the oil sands
but the industry oil industry here said
that they needed that pipeline to
deliver their oil to market
this town has kind of been waiting to
see what happens
uh
[Music]
for more on this let's bring in our
resident green expert hotshot
rati akshat the cancellation of this
project led to job losses that doesn't
help the economic recovery that we need
could you put that into context for us
that's certainly right we know that tc
energy
has laid out about 1000 jobs connected
to the project
and in this environment any job losses
aren't welcome but there's a bigger
story here
and the environmentalists argue that
it's not just about one pipeline
the goal is to try and wean the entire
society of fossil fuels
so yes in any transition you will have
some job losses
but what's coming in the form of green
energy
and what could be a green recovery will
create
many times more jobs and put out fewer
emissions
why is it fossil fuel pipelines that
have become such a hot button issue what
do they mean specifically for climate
change
yeah it's a funny one you know pipelines
in themselves don't produce
any emissions it's really the stuff that
is carried in them
either oil or gas that will end up
producing emissions
but because governments have not been
acting
as urgently as the science asks
that they act it's left
environmentalists with
very few options so the ideal outcome
would be
governments put a carbon tax and society
adjusts to this new normal
that's not happening and so what they do
is they try
and um essentially pinch at the points
that they can
and pipelines are one that you can have
a plan on because they go through other
people's lands and you can
make a case for why that is not
something that you would like
society to have so pipelines part of the
plan but obviously president biden has a
broader
climate agenda how is the oil industry
going to need to adapt to that what do
they have to do
it's going to be a time of disruption
because the oil and gas industry now
with biden
in the white house has been given a very
clear signal
that climate change is something that
this administration is going to take
very seriously
and not just the pipeline we uh
understood this week that
the biden administration is cancelling
oil and gas leases on federal lands
which is a huge swath of the country and
so
what the oil industry really needs to do
now is to
absorb the fact that the energy
transition is here
that we need to be able to find
ourselves
using fewer and fewer fossil fuels in
the future
and it would be helpful if the oil and
gas industry
takes this as an opportunity and figures
out what types of clean energy it can
provide
all right the energy transition is here
thank you so much to bloomberg's
offshore roti
that's all for this week but you can
keep the conversation going
follow us on twitter at climate i'm
kaylee lyons in new york
and this is bloomberg green